We're on problem 79.
A small business owner must hire
seasonal workers as the
need arises.
The following list shows the
number of employees hired
monthly for a five-month
period.
OK, so we hired 4 in the first
month, 13 in the second
month and so on.
If the mean of these data--
remember, data is plural.
I always say this data, but if
they correctly say if the mean
of these data is approximately
7.
So the mean is the
average, right?
So they're saying the average
of these numbers is 7.
Fair enough.
If you add all of these up and
divide by 5, you'll get
approximately 7.
What is the population standard
deviation for these data?
So, with population-- I'll make
a statistical playlist
one day where I talk about
the difference between a
population, standard deviation,
and a sample
standard deviation
and all that.
But the population standard
deviation, just you have an
intuition, it's a measure of,
on average, how far are each
of these numbers
from the mean?
And it's not exactly the average
of how far they are
from the mean, but I'll show
you that in a second.
It's actually the square root of
the average of the squared
distances of how far each of
these are from the median.
And that might sound crazy for
a second, but when you
actually work it all out
the math isn't too bad.
So what we'll do first is
figure out the variance.
That's the notation
for the variance.
And the standard deviation
actually is just the square
root of this.
So if you have the variance,
it's very easy to figure out
the standard deviation.
But the variance-- and just to
give you the intuition-- it's
equal to the average
of the squared
distances from the mean.
So essentially I say, OK
how far is 4 from 7?
Oh it's 3 away.
And I square it.
I say, OK, the squared
distance is 9.
The squared distance here,
let me figure it out.
So let's actually
write them down.
Let me actually calculate it.
So I'll do it here.
4 minus 7 is minus 3.
If I were to square
that, I'd get 9.
So the square of the distance
from 4 to 7 is 9.
So that's a squared distance.
So the squared distance
from 13 to 7.
See, they're 6 apart.
You square them.
And because we're squaring it
doesn't matter if we do 7
minus 12 or 13 minus 7.
Because a negative times a
negative is a positive.
Anyway 13 minus 7 is 6.
That squared is 36.
Then I have 5 minus 7.
That's minus 2 squared
is equal to 4.
Then I have 6 minus 7.
That's negative 1.
Squared is equal to 1.
And then I have 9 minus 7.
That's 2.
Squared is equal to 4.
So the 9 is the square of
how far 4 is from 7.
36 is a square of how
far 13 is from 7.
So each of these are the squared
distances of each the
data points from the mean.
That's where we got
the 7 from, the
average of these numbers.
Now, we said the variance
is the average
of the squared distances.
So it's just the average
of these five numbers.
So what's the average of
these five numbers?
It's going to be 9
plus 36 is 45.
Plus 4 is 49.
Plus 1 is 50.
Plus 1 is 54.
So it's going to be 54 divided
by, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
Divided by 5.
So the variance is equal
to the average
of the squared distances.
And that's-- what?
10 and 4/5 is equal to 10.8.
So that's the variance.
They don't want the variance.
They don't want the population
variance.
They want the population
standard deviation.
Well that's just the square
of the variance.
And you can see, since you're
taking the square of the
square distances, it kind of
becomes close to the average
of the real distances.
But it's actually not that
and I don't want to
confuse you right now.
For the sake of this problem,
let's just take the square
root of this.
So the standard deviation
is just equal to the
square root of the.
Variance Which is equal to
the square root of 10.8.
And what is that?
Let's see, 3 squared is 9.
4 squared is 16.
So the square root of 10.8 is
going to be pretty close to 3.
Between 3 and 4 but
a lot closer to 3.
And if we look at all the
choices, the only one that
even comes close is this one.
I think if you actually found
the square root it's actually
very close to 3.3.
Next problem.
James found the mean and
standard deviation of the set
of numbers given above.
If he adds 5 to each number,
which of the
following will result?
All right.
If you add 5.
The mean will be multiplied
by 5.
No, no, no.
That's not right.
Because if you add 5 to each
of these numbers, the mean
will just become 5 bigger.
You're kind of just
shifting over the
center to some degree.
Where you're measuring the
center by the average over 5.
Actually I could even
show it to you.
If I said 3 plus 5, and I'm
going to add that to 6 plus 5
plus 2 plus 5.
I'm adding 5 to every number.
Plus 2 plus 5.
Plus 1 plus 5.
Plus 7 plus 5.
Plus 5 plus 5.
All of that divided
by-- there's, 1,
2, 3, 4, 5, 6 numbers.
All of that divided by 6.
This is the same thing as-- let
me write this-- if we, we
can get rid of parentheses.
All we're doing is adding.
So that's the same thing
as 3 plus 6 plus 2 plus
1 plus 7 plus 5.
I just took the first terms
in each of these.
Plus-- how many 5s do we have?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Plus 6 times 5.
All of that over 6.
Well, this is going to be equal
to 3 plus 6 plus 2 plus
1 plus 7 plus 5, over 6.
Let me scroll down
a little bit.
Plus-- what's 6 times
5 divided by 6?
Well that's just 5.
So this is the average of the
original set of numbers.
And now, when you add 5 to all
of them, the average of all of
them combined is just going
to be the original
average plus 5.
So you're just shifting the
average to the right.
So this is not right.
You're not multiplying
the mean by 5.
You're just adding
5 to the mean.
That's not right.
The standard deviation
will increase by 5.
Well, in the last video you
saw that the standard
deviation is the square
root of the variance.
But both of them are a measure
of the average distance of the
numbers from the mean,
or from the average.
So even if you shift everything
by 5-- the mean
shifts by 5, all the numbers
shift by 5-- their distances
from the mean aren't going
to change, actually.
The standard deviation actually
won't change.
So this isn't right.
The standard deviation
won't increase by 5.
These numbers aren't going
to become further
away from the average.
So that's not right.
The mean will not change.
Well, no.
We know that the mean
will change.
I just showed you that
the mean will
actually increase by 5.
When all the numbers have
increased by 5.
That's not right.
So we already know that D
is probably the answer,
but let's make sure.
The standard deviation
will not change.
Right.
In general, the average
dispersion, or how far on
average the numbers are away
from the mean, won't change.
All the numbers are going to
increase by 5 and the mean is
going to increase by 5.
So how far the numbers are from
the mean, their variance
won't change.
The square of their distances
And if the variance doesn't
change, then
the mean won't change.
So the answer's definitely D.
And we're all done.
See you in the next playlist.